ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di vita buttata il tema di oggi
è un rullo di tamburi università da una
parte ho deciso di accogliere l'invito
della luiss che m'ha chiesto di
condividere la mia esperienza
universitaria dall'altra in realtà ho
accolto anche i due milioni i
suggerimenti che sono sempre gravitati
attorno al mondo dell'università tema
così importante
ho pensato di invitare all'interno degli
studios di casa mia un ospite che ho
selezionato in maniera estremamente
attenta una persona che forse l'unica
laureata tra tutti nei cugini e c'è
qualcun altro non lo so sto parlando
comunque dell'avvocato scannerini al
secolo mia cugina lavinia della
presentazione contro un onore per me
calcare questo palcoscenico allora
settimana to giulia si erano laureati e
poi soprattutto come dimenticare mai
vive che mai parlato del cugino e c'è
una buona parte in corsa per scappare il
tema è fuggita parliamo di università
come sempre prima di iniziare a fare una
chiacchiera personale e facciamo le
chiacchiere diciamo ascoltando quelli
che sono i messaggi che ci sembra tenuta
è la mia parte preferita partiamo eccoci
la cosa che in assoluto
io preferisco quest'albero che sta
nell'aula e che trapassa il soffitto
aspetto c'è ma è un albero parti si sta
laureando in scienze botaniche cioè
perché se no non c'è una ratio ma che
sfonda possiamo farlo vedere un secondo
al metal
l'albero nell'alto il mio desiderio era
da sempre volete lavorare con i bambini
ma mio padre mi ha sempre detto
conoscendo il mio carattere secondo lui
sarei impazzita all'interno di un asilo
plancia forse l'ha detto anche per
salvaguardare la vita di quelle creature
povere creature in realtà un po mi ha
convinta a fare economia e commercio
evidentemente luce ha visto lungo perché
adesso uno stipendio davvero molto buono
mi sto togliendo tantissime
soddisfazioni e quindi grazie
lo sai come ben sai che è molto simile
in realtà per grace volvo una
professione che è un mash up perfetto
tra le mie soft skills cosa sono
iscritto kit sono le attitudini che tu
hai creatività grandi doti di
comunicazione le abilità di lavorabile
di l'anno e quindi prescindono dallo
studio che precedono dallo studio è che
se non riesce a veicolare beni ad
allenare e va ad incanalare bene dentro
l'altro il tuo cursus honorum noi la
carriera lavorativa
ti volevo fare studi storico artistici
mio padre mi disse mi fece il discorso
pop alla muffa fa capitò princi un
giorno tutto questo sarà tuo
ma devi fabris prudenza ascoltare i
consigli secondo me è molto importante
perché quando sei giovane rischi di
essere un po miope su te stesso io per
esempio adesso sono giovanissime sarei
in grado di capire che cosa pare di
capire che cosa va la mia vita io
sommesso 10 15 anni a capire che
realmente io sia
devo essere dove volevo essere io sono
10 15 anni che ancora non capisco dove
sconta ancora né quello che voglio fare
mesi a volte sentono queste ore allora
quando facevo l'università a un esame al
fine esame professore mi dà 29 io
chiedendogli se poteva darmi 30 come
dice che avevo risposto alle domande
importante sbagliando e quindi il
massimo che poteva darmi era 29 io tiro
fuori libretto mi esce fuori uno stemma
della roma perché sono tifoso rossonero
guarda e mi dice tutto serio mi dica
alla formazione della roma dell 82 83 a
partire dal portiere
l'eretico mida 30 sempre serio senza mai
suo leader è derivato a casa contento
che questa faccia come il corno come
ormai della ribattezzata io non ce l'ho
mai avuta nella mia intera esistenza e
la invidio ma in realtà nemmeno io
no non è vero io sono una che fa per me
è un insieme di cose che secondo me ad
oggi non tutte le università fanno ora
perché sto parlando della luiss ma la
lui se è effettivamente un posto del
quale i rapporti sono stato ospite per
fare delle chiacchiere cose così
ma nord si e hanno un sacco di corsa
workshop e compagnia bella sei tu riesce
a salire come di sorridere incazzate
onda incazzarti ea trattare le persone
nella maniera in maniera intelligente
poi d'accordo sul ponte è il motivo per
cui io non faccio niente perché sono
capaci allora studiare a me non è mai
piaciuto
[Risate]
io ho fatto nella mia storia
universitaria e barry copa
che io invece cerco di dimenticare tre
scelte totalmente diversi e ho avuto
solamente persone che in famiglia mi
hanno detto avvocato avvocato avvocato
visto tutti avvocati le vere 7 rivede da
quando soffre oggi leggo
a me fa schifo e bellissimo guarda come
mi fa schifo e la professione più bella
del mondo
ma sento qualcuno che avesse insistito
di più avrei fatto come dicevo io ero
una pippa al liceo
però adesso assegnato all'università
però purtroppo rimasto uno che si tratta
come persone fa intellettuale allora mi
rendo conto che tratta il mondo con la
stessa moneta con la moneta di un giusto
disagio ciao gu
allora per la sezione università io
domenica suonato lo stadio vedere
bologna parma e tifo al bologna e per
l'intera partita
ho mandato a fare in un signore che
tifava parma giustamente da tifoso per
tutta la partita se ne stiamo arrivando
a tutti i colori giorni dopo averle same
same ma c'è l'assistente indovino
se si fosse lo stabile no no
sostanzialmente adesso anche andato a
fare l'esame era un ascolto per tutti i
peggiori su di me partimento qualsiasi
cosa cambia qualsiasi cosa che è una
sfida incredibile corato il mascara e
sono venuta gentina sudare in italia mi
piace tantissimo tanto il vostro paese e
vi sono fidanzata con un italiano che
però non è invasiva beh si può mica mica
ho detto micheli da università mi piace
un sacco il coordinata che sto facendo e
bellissimo però sono stanca di farmi la
doccia ogni volta che vanno a lezione
c'è qualcuno deve dire che il mio
professore di smettere di sputare vado a
elezioni con l'ombrello anche quando
fuori c'è menzione che spacca le pietre
mi fido in quarta fila arriva a
pallonetto con il cucchiaio dei piloti e
mettere in realtà in primissima fila ha
di sé che ti sai che ti salta oppure c'è
il rischio che la prima fila invece sia
proprio quella lì che ha impattato per
prima contro l'iceberg del tipo mi trovo
senza lavoro e senza studio non c'è
stato nessuno che mi ha incoraggiato a
farlo allora cover in banda c il
curriculum 6 forse un ion aneddoto che
vi riguarda riguarda questo format
perché prima di un esame universitario
guardai un episodio di vita buttata
quello con la tematica botta di 36
l'esame
da lì in poi prima di ogni esame ho
sempre guardato questo video sempre
portato fortuna insomma ho finito gli
esami e quindi ti ringrazio v ringrazio
tutto il team perché siete veramente una
bella squadra
fate passare dei messaggi veramente in
forma gravi vi ringrazio e ciao a tutti
ora che ho sentito questa ragazza ho
pensato che io ho fatto 32 esami con le
stesse mutande e io senza volevo tante
usare mai andata a sostenere un esame ma
davvero ormai si completamente l'audio
perché mio padre che mi ha iscritto a
medicina o alla spiegazione di letta e
giro nella la scritta forza di nota si
calcola che ogni giorno gli appuntamenti
ad una foto di partiti vede la porta per
far ricredere stessi studiando ma da
loro e sana google è tanto difficile la
scelta universitaria perché non sai mai
se lo scegli perché ti stanno
costringendo lo sceglie per tra cui
davvero lo sceglie perché se gli amici o
pensi non saper fare altro ci sono così
tanti fattori dietro la scelta
universitaria che vengono secondo me
fatti comunque in un'età che ha ancora
abbastanza critica è certo è per questo
che devi farti aiutare ma tutti rendi
conto che questo ragazzo ora deve per
forza dire delle cavolate
ci sono un sacco di persone hanno
conosciuto uno in particolare che ha
finto direttore di laurearsi senza
affittate laurearti affitti operarsi
si è stampato il finto diploma tutto
quanto ha fatto invitato la gente ha
fatto una festa
no perché ha detto che non hanno fatto
quel giorno la discussione perché visto
che era santo pistacchio di quanto al
formaggio alla fine mi hanno cancellato
la seduta ma poi quando gliel'hanno
rinviare no bella così è andata come se
avessi fatto prossima a così ex fi è
veramente un qualcosa di super super
delicato quindi il mio invito veramente
quello di iniziate a pensarci presto io
per esempio ci ho pensato troppo tardi e
che allo stesso tempo
fatevi dare una mano da chi vi vuole
bene e chi vi conosce e chi è anche
disposto ad accettare il fatto che voi
non seguire il suo consiglio ma che anzi
il suo consiglio vi aiuterà a chiarire
ancora di più le idee ancora volta
grazie a lui se grazie a voi per averci
dato questa opportunità meravigliosa
ringrazio ravin per questo video grazie
mille per il bene prezioso apporto
vi invito proprio contributo tributo
umano
scrivere di questo canale mettere un
pollice in su farci sapere qual è stata
la nostra esperienza ci vediamo domani
con una nuova puntata del blog mas
ciao